[Music]
okay so I'll start today's a last
lecture so I'm going to do two
applications of SVD and hopefully
there'll be somewhat atypical so you see
the second one is certainly a typical
it's to do with max cut and graphs
the first one is mixture of gaussians
right which may be a little more
familiar subset I mean max cut hopefully
won't be so familiar right so clustering
in general is a problem of partitioning
data points into K subsets so often K is
given so this is K clustering problem
but in some times you can worry about K
not being given but usually K is given K
sets of points and of course you know
evolves we have to formulate the how to
measure the quality of clustering and
then ask for the best possible right so
there are many formulations I mean this
is a big subject right so one
formulation is you minimize the sum of
distances this is the most popular
formulation in theoretical computer
science but actually the most sensible
formulation is this perhaps right in
statistics where you take the sum of
squared distances and squared distances
they have all the advantages that we had
for SVD and so on so forth so these
problems are all pretty hard
gently np-hard so you don't you can't
solve them exactly around solving around
NP hardness one is approximate optimal
solutions this is what in operations
researcher computer science you often do
but the difficulty with that is even
with just relative error epsilon they
may become completely useless and I will
see show you an example of that or what
we'll do here or perhaps what is more
familiar in machine learning of
statistics is the following you assume a
stochastic model of data so stochastic
model means a hidden hand or hidden
model which you don't know generates the
data and you have to cluster now no
errors allowed in general
it's often not interesting to do it only
approximately so you want exactly as the
hidden model generated so we will see
examples of we'll see the sort of most
familiar examples also mixture models
are an important cause of stochastic
models what our mixture models may share
of K densities probability densities
let's say this is just a way that some
convex combination non-negative weights
and summing to one the idea is i give
you i generate according to some f i
don't tell you f
I don't tell you the W's and peace I
give you just samples and you have to
find the best W sin piece or in general
I guarantee there is one and you have to
find the exact one assuming some
conditions so the learning problem is
just given n iid samples from a mixture
learnt the mixture so find all those
find all those WS and peace so you I
have to give you something if it can be
make sure of anything nothing can be
done so what I will give you is basic
density I won't give you the exact piece
and W is of course that's a problem but
I'll tell you for instance there
gaussians here that's what's going to
happen here and in fact they have
spherical Gaussian in this case a
spherical Gaussian in D dimensions which
just has probability density deviation e
to the minus the length of the vector x
squared over 2 Sigma squared and it's of
course equal to
product over I equals 1 to D e to the
minus X I squared so Sigma is the
standard deviation but you notice that
it's the same in each component right
it just sectors so so what's the
clustering problem I haven't told you
what the clustering problem is so might
as well look at that there are two ways
you can think of samples being generated
they give you the same probability
distribution so either might be possible
one is just pick each sample according
to the mixture F which we had in the
last slide just one remark I should have
made is that this is also a probability
density and integrates to 1 right
because these W sum to 1 if you ain't
integrate this you'll get one also so so
one way of generating is just F is a
density generated iid samples the other
way of generating is pick one of the
components between 1 and K there are K
components and I'm going to generate
from the ith component I pick an X
according to P I so an example which
probably is good to have is you have a
mixture of these two probability
densities let's say so I take half of
this x plus sorry plus half of this I
get a density which sort of has two by
two molds that's my density right this
is the sum so I can generate from this
mixture just having the whole mixture in
my hand just a hidden name right or I
can generate I'm oregan say eat some I'm
gonna generate from this or that with
probability 1/2 each I picked that and
then pick X according to clearly they
give you the same distribution right so
the learning problem has two sub
problems then we for the learning
problem you use you use the method to of
generating and there's two sub problems
one is cluster data into K clusters
according to which P I was
used to generate each of those samples
right so in this picture half the
samples will come from here and the
other half of the samples will come from
there okay so the clustering problem is
to split separate them like that it's to
figure out what the hidden hand used to
do right so that's a harder problem then
you also have to once you've done the
clustering once I've said once I've said
this is one cluster this is another
cluster I have to fit this density to
that and that density to that that's
very easy right fitting a single
Gaussian to a set of points is very easy
you just take the mean and standard
deviation of the sample and pretend that
was this generating thing that's quite
accurate so we'll only worry about the
clustering problem that's that's the
interesting problem so here's a mnemonic
that we want to remember for the day
that you all know so you holler heard of
right means separated by six standard
deviations or I'm going to say the
constant number of standard deviations
now if the Gaussian components have
centers that are very close together
than clustering is impossible in the
limit they could just be on top of each
other they could be the same Gaussian
then you cannot tell for example which
cause you know generated it from obvious
leaders they could could be either one
in one dimension a separation of a
constant number of standard deviation
that's what this mnemonic about 60
divisions is right is necessary
insufficient first if you have a
separation which is much smaller than a
constant this all one means goes to zero
as n goes to infinity right then it's
hopeless so why is it hopeless because
so then your one Gaussian one another
one like that then I get points but
points here could have come from either
this for that there's no way you can
necessarily tell in fact you could get
samples from this that are on this side
that lie on this side so there's no way
to tell which so it's clear that it's
clear that you need that much but if the
separation is large in
then you can find everything okay maybe
a little more careful if you want to get
everything right to get all correct need
root login standard deviations
separation
I won't prove this because of e to the x
squared e to the minus x squared right
if you have this with high probability
everyone will be correct I can be
correctly but you if you want to get
more straight then you don't need the
root log in sorry in the N is the number
of data points dimensions one for this
so far yeah it's even in one dimension
you need root login separation if you
want to get everything right in one
dimension and so when I say constant its
with a pinch of salt that only gets most
things right right or I have to put a
star on it to say log factors the main
purpose of today is to prove that this
also works the same mnemonic works even
if the dimension of D is going to
infinity as long as K is constant okay
so we need only number of standard
deviation separation which depends on K
but not on D in any dimension so these
to be thought of as they're large right
we we're always dealing with high
dimensional data but that does not
affect how much separation we need
that's what you'd like to prove will
prove that but one quick thing
calculation will do in the beginning is
it's not anymore going to be true so in
one in in one dimension I should have
said that in 1d distance-based works
distance based clustering what
with Omega Sigma separation I'm still
being waved because I mean we'll state
precise theorems but it does not work as
D becomes large as D grows okay we'll
see that first and then see what we can
do instead right and of course yeah the
key will be SVD that this is all about
SVD right so two applications where this
is an application so limits of distance
based clustering why it doesn't work so
let's look at D dimensions now x and y
are iid from the st. spherical Gaussian
this is just a spherical Gaussian it's a
correct normalizing constant this is a
spherical Gaussian with variance Sigma
squared then we already saw this and
I'll recap it with pictures but not
necessarily go over the entire
calculation the distance squared between
x and y is roughly this quantity this
was the Gaussian annulus theorem is
worth recalling so the picture so the
picture is that one Gaussian is like
that and other Gaussian is here the
separation between these two distance
Delta and the standard deviations are
Sigma right so these are this sorry
again this distance recall is roughly
root D times Sigma right there are D
dimensions the variances add up so the
variance together is D times Sigma
squared and I take the square root I get
this right and furthermore we saw that
most of the probability mass is in an
annulus of it constant
this is order signal everything is
scaled by standard deviation so most of
the mass flies there and similarly for
this
this calculation we did this picture but
this calculation is X&Y from the same
sample so here is X and here's why right
from the same Gaussian sorry from the
same Gaussian right and I want to know
the distance between x and y and the
picture is not going to look to reflect
what I'm going to say but X to the
center of that Gaussian this is mu1
center of gaussian ones is the center of
gaussian - I take that and I take that
this angle is 90 degrees
well not exactly approximately 90
degrees right we saw that that theorem
had a name that's the equator theorem
right so if I pick these are independent
samples so I could have pretended I
picked X first make it a North Pole and
then Y lies in the equator that said
this that's approximately 90 degrees so
that's why you get the distance between
them as a sum of squares of these two so
that's just Pythagoras theorem except
it's not exactly Rudy right it's Rudy
plus or minus a constant and we have to
square it in Sigma squared everything is
in standard deviation units what happens
if you have two samples and now that is
from it from the from this Gaussian
access to the first Gaussian X and zero
samples from different spherical
gaussians standard deviation Sigma means
separated by Delta then this this and
this are all perpendicular this is 90
degrees this is 90 degrees roughly
and why was that right so excellent
rather independent I pickaxe make that
the North Pole now X itself this angle
will be 90 degrees with high probability
because here this is a fixed this is a
fixed axis right this is not random I've
fixed mu 1 mu 2 this is fixed so X will
be perpendicular to that roughly guess
that defines an equator and then once X
is fixed and of course mu 1 mu 2 is
fixed that is independent so it'll be
perpendicular to both of those
that's like saying two equators right
and that's still true that most of the
mass lies in that and therefore X minus
x squared will be again plus or minus
Sigma squared plus Delta squared again
Pythagoras right three days so now we
want to ensure that a pairs of samples
from the same Gaussian are always closer
than pairs of samples from different
Gaussian if you want that then we better
have with a minus sign here because it
could be this it could be that X and Zed
are only this distance apart and it
could be that x and y or this distance
apart
does the worst that can happen to you
right x and y or within the root d plus
or minus but plus is the worst and
similarly here minus is the worst if you
expand this you see that the leading
term cancels out right to D to D cancels
out and then you get a root D here let
us beaten up by Delta so this only works
if Delta is at least D to the fourth
root right it's D to the fourth power so
that's the limit of distance based
clustering if the center's are less than
D to the 4th power apart then it will
not work what will not work means that
if I just take a point and take its
closest points I will not necessarily
get all samples from the same Gaussian I
will get some corruption
these arguments go both ways so I will
get some corruption if we have less than
D to the 1/4 separation so this doesn't
meet our mnemonic of means separated by
a constant number of standard deviations
because D is going to infinity okay so I
cannot do this right I cannot just do
this I will do this actually but I will
have to do something before that okay so
not means separated by order one
standard deviation so of course there
sweetie this application or SVD will
show that using SVD that this still can
be made to work at the bottom will be a
distance based clustering we'll be doing
this but not in the full space so so the
idea is going to be that I'm going to
project to their sweety surface and
cluster this is an important idea
actually it's the only way I know of
doing many things correctly which is to
project their 3d subspace and cluster
there so what do we do we project all
data points to the space spanned by the
top K sorry excuse me backtrack suppose
they can find the subspace spanned by
the K center's K centers the component
gaussians in this case mu 1 and V 2 in
this example is d dimensional this this
is the subspace right suppose I can find
this line the origin is somewhere here
let's say for a moment then I find this
fine suppose I found this line then I
have to draw another picture kidding doc
so I project to that line then the
picture looks like this
okay so then it basically looks like
that and that's because it's easy to
show and maybe we'll go to the
calculation a projector deafspace
projection aesthetical gaussian still is
spherical and it has the same standard
deviation you have to do a little
argument I think maybe I have a slight
arguing this is just simple argument
that the standard deviation remains the
same so projection to the space of
centers why does it work because it
preserves inter center separation right
so one good thing I didn't put up on the
slides maybe it's worth doing we know
two dimension reduction techniques one
is SVD which we go through the other one
is random projection so random
projection does not work and doesn't
work because if I do random projection
standard deviations preserved there the
this that's always true for any
projection now what happens to the inter
center separation
so I'm going to do a random projection
to kate k space to a random k space so
we are sitting in these space I think's
project down to a randomly chosen K
dimensional space we know we already saw
theorem that tells us what happens to
the inter Center separations what what
happens to them do they remain the same
this was Johnson Lyndon Strauss theorem
right
they don't remain the same we're sitting
in these space all dimensions are
roughly the same because they're doing a
random projection so the inter center
separation is multiplied by root K over
T photography so squares get multiplied
by K over D you're projecting to K out
of D dimensions right so everything will
shrink in square photographers by K over
D so in the distance will actually
shrink so this is not very nice for us
right because what we want is from the
last slide if we want to do just a
distance based clustering what we want
is inter center separation that's my
Delta divided by whatever dimension you
project to to the one fourth right times
Sigma is greater than a constant
so we did not have this in the big space
that's why we are projecting but if the
projection does has this property this
is not very good so I'm sorry this is
time standard DVF
well I put on this so the dimension has
come down which is nice but so has this
right so what we have done is this
remains this is multiplied by root K
over D this remains the same
unfortunately what's happened to this it
used to be D to the 1/4 it's become K to
the 1/4 right so it's been multiplied by
K or D to the 1/4
it shouldn't work out that this yeah
okay it doesn't work out right so we we
we get that this is roughly K or D to
the 1/4 but K is much smaller than D
case constant D is going to infinity
right D is growing that's what we had so
this is no good because it shrinks
random projections shrinks the inter
centre separation okay preserves
standard deviation it's not so bad but
it thinks that so that's no good
however SVD will do the job for us I
mean sorry not a Swede yet for the
moment projecting to the space of
indigent inter center space of centers
preserves the inter centers separation
preserves the numerator and also the
denominator but the dimension has come
down so it's nice so the ratio improves
right dimension used to be deed became
cape
so the ratio improves okay so so if if
the Sigma hype was at least K to the 1/4
case now a constant then this should
work provided we do it in the projection
so K is constant so this is a constant
number of standard deviations of art
then distance based clustering now we do
distance basically in the projection we
do this what I said in the last light
but in the projection the smaller space
yeah how would these how would we know
with samples of from which one to be
able to so that's a difficulty right you
have to somehow know which samples
belong to which Gaussian before you pull
them apart but that's the main problem
so I don't know way where random
projection can be used to do this
actually
so we'll prove that a so the main of
main thing once I tell you this use you
the proof is not difficult at all it but
it's quite quite beautiful actually this
is you too when Paul unwound the pit the
references are in the book you can you
can see that so will prove that the
space spanned by the top K singular
vectors of the data is in fact the space
of centers in the limit as you get
infinitely many samples but finite
sample it's approximately true okay
again we know how to do a 3d so we find
the top K single vectors that is the
assertion is that is essentially the
space of centered so that word I don't
know the space of centers because I
don't know the clustering problem has to
be solved to determine which one is the
center of each Gaussian so and it's this
is saying I can do it without clustering
this know this actually mostly comes
from symmetry of spherical gaussians we
see the argument as I say is very nice
argument and very simple I mean so lemma
projection preserves the STD aesthetical
curves you know this I asserted without
proof I did write down a proof of this
okay so maybe we'll go over a proof of
this I'll go over it quickly because
this is something you can verify at home
this is just handed right so we want to
project over their subspace V and we
want to say standard deviation is
preserved for vertical gaussians we
rotate the coordinate systems first K
coordinates of this I take an X in D
space project this is the projection
this is what's left and so the density
in the projection is just I integrate
out new double prime right i projected
onto the first k i integrate out these
things so if I integrate that out that's
just a constant the whole point just is
that for a Gaussian distinct split right
some of these tools right it's just only
Pythagoras again right always so that
follows again please you can check this
yourself right now I come
comes a nice spot proving that the SVD
finds a space of centers here's the idea
and then we'll go with a proof in some
detail show that the top K singular
vectors produced by the SVD span the
space of K centers and that's only going
to be exactly true as a number of iid
samples from the mixture goes to
infinity it's not going to be true for a
finite sample case but as the number of
samples goes to infinity that's going to
be true so to do that first I'm going to
extend the definition of best fit to
infinitely many samples or to
probability distributions instead of
finite number
so best fit was defined for a finite
number of data points I want to define
for infinite number of data points or
for distributions but quite a
straightforward way we do that then we
show that for a single spherical
Gaussian whose center is not the origin
the best at one dimensional subspace is
unique and it's aligned through the
center of the Gaussian and the origin so
there is a picture in the book I mean
I'm not sure how illustrator the picture
is but let's draw that
so we have a Gaussian with Center mu and
the origin is somewhere maybe inside the
millions right here okay the claim is
the best fit one dimensional subspace is
certainly passes through the origin and
also passes from you there's only one
line like that that is the best fit
right it's better than everybody else I
mean the rough reason is symmetry if you
had a line going like this
Caroline like this why is it worse
let's take distances to the line there
are these points with very high
perpendicular distance there of course
some points with very low perpendicular
distance right but the high ones
dominate because we are squaring and
adding okay that's square please are all
there whereas for this one most points
are roughly at the same distance it's
pretty concentrated most points or sort
of at that distance okay so it's equal
but we will prove it the proof is
algebraically is going to be written
down it's not that difficult but we'll
prove that that the best fit line is for
one Gaussian the best set line whose
origin is not whose center is not the
origin the best fit one dimensional
substrate is aligned through the
Gaussian now once I tell you this the
proof is almost there right why is that
because we now are give next that we
show the best fit k dimensional subspace
for a single Gaussian whose center is
not the origin now this is by symmetry
if I want a plane that's the best fit
the I mean just by symmetry kind of
argument its it follows that it should
it should contain that point okay but
there's another way we'll see this
another way we'll see this and that's by
the greedy algorithm right remember as
we do the greedy algorithm but so if I
want to find the best at k dimensional
surface I first find the best at one
dimensional subspace right which I saw
which I told you here passes through the
center so it's a one dimensional
subspace right then I project I project
perpendicular to this line that's how I
find the second singular vector right
that's clearly now the projection is
this one but in the projection I get a
sphere centered at the origin this is
the projection center of the Gaussian is
now the origin right because I'm
projecting perpendicular to that and
once I have a Gaussian passing through
the origin all lines are the same
completely symmetric okay therefore this
thing will follow the best K dimensional
subspace for one Gaussian is any
subspace that contains the origin in the
center and now we're done because for if
you had case vertical gaussians the best
K dimensional subspace
for each one individually is the
substrate containing the Centers now if
I contain all the centers then I must be
the best for each individual one
therefore for the some right so for each
individual one if I produce any K
dimensional subspace that contains its
center and I'm fine now if I contain all
K centers then this says individually
this is the best K dimensional best fit
subspace for each one individually so
it's clearly true for the song so that's
the argument so we'll go with that are
there any questions I mean basically
I've given you the proof but we'll do it
carefully I mean it's worth absorbing
this proof right against very simple but
quite nice
in depending on the mixing there's yeah
that's a point that's a nice thing is
independent mixing proportions and in
fact it's independent of the radii so we
are doing it for the same Sigma in this
I mean as I've been indicating so it may
be that the gaussians are spherical of
different radii yeah it's all everything
is symmetrical so but it's only true for
spherical gaussians right I mean so we
used heavily this spherical symmetry
there are some versions of this for non
spherical gaussians which are not as
good but still for spherical it's very
simple so we'll take a few minutes to
try to pin down this proof but it's
basically essentially here so recall the
best-fit line is a line passing through
the origin maximizing the sum of squared
projections so we want first to define
what best it means for probability
densities entry points which is an
integral instead of a sum so best
deadline for probability density px is
reliant v1 which maximizes is it's an
expectation it's an integral right for
if you had individual data points X I
would have summed it over all the data
points right now I have X is a random
variable so is sum over I take the
expected value of the sum of squared
projections I took max because I took
the projection right if I take the
distance to the liner attic limit for
spherical gas it's centered at 0 any
line passing through 0 is the best-fit
line so if the is there as you know
Center at 0 everything is symmetric it
doesn't matter what line through the
origin you take clearly by symmetry this
is all the same so for circle Gaussian
density P centered at MU which is not 0
there's a unique best one-dimensional
subspace best fit subspace and it's the
one that passes through 0 and mu okay
said verbally earlier now is it the
center is 0 than any line through zeros
the best fit okay so this is the
argument for
or this is the proof which I'll give
behind waiving symmetry right so this
stands for the expectation over random
vectors X picked according to density P
that's what this stands for right and
then I take V dot x squared expected
value and they write this as V dot X
minus Mew Mews the center of the
Gaussian plus V dot new squid and I
expand that so these are just real
numbers now the dot products so this is
a squared plus B squared there's a - a B
term which I obviously had dropped so
there's a third term in the whole
squared expansion which is expectation X
picked according to P of V dot X minus
mu V dot mu right I've dropped this why
is that X is random V is not random so I
can remove this out so that's equal to V
dot mu and I can remove two out picked
according to this of V dot X minus mu
right and again V is fixed so I could
remove that we out expect sorry I could
remove that V out and say V dot
expectation over X picked according to
this of X minus mu so I guess I should
have a good so this is a vector this is
expected value of a random vector X is a
random variable but vector value it
takes vector values right D dimensional
but I can do this with our product it's
doctor practices linear operations I can
remove we are this is zero right
because muse the center of the Gaussian
so the expected value of x is new so the
cross term goes out it always goes out
we did a few calculations like this
earlier so this is now the variance of Y
is life because see I took X minus mu
now that's just Gaussian centered at the
origin dot we and the square of that
that's the variance in the direction V
okay this whole thing is a variance in
the direction V but spherical so
variance is the same in all directions
they get Sigma squared so that thing is
independent of V that's very important
right I mean because because it's just
the variance okay so we get this and now
we're done right now they think that
maximizes this must happen okay best fit
maximizes lat
that quantity so maximizes V dot mu
because this is constant and this is
maximized when V is aligned with center
new unit vector in the direction that's
what makes maximum dot product so see
the uniqueness so this says that V in
the direction of you does maximize in
the uniqueness also obvious right if mu
is not 0 and V is not aligned with you
it's strictly less this is continued
extend the definition now to K
dimensions of spaces again we had
already defined what's the best fit KD
subspace or finite number of points for
us up for a for a density we just do
that we integrate interest some expect
value of x so among all k dimensional
spaces this is true I mean this is a
definition for a spherical Gaussian with
center mu we want to prove a K
dimensional subspace is the best it's
subspace if and only if it contains mu
for the line it had to continue also but
now that's saying it for every game
if mu is a second part if mu zero by
symmetry any K dimension surfaces the
best fit everything is symmetric so I
could take any one okay if mu is not
zero so mu zero we're done right this
lemma is for both mu 0 not 0 mu 0 as a
simple case there's nothing to prove
Mew is not 0 then the best fit line
we already saw must pass through mu by
earlier lemma that was the lemma in the
last slide one-dimensional line now as
in the greedy algorithm so this requires
some proof that the greedy works for
probability densities in place of just
finite number of points but that's
straightforward so we'll assume the
greedy words we project perpendicular
the first singular vector but after the
projection it's centered at 0 that this
picture oh that's ok well maybe I won't
draw a picture so you've got a line
going through the origin and I'm
projecting perpendicular to that now the
origin is the center it's a 0 centered
Gaussian and therefore this thing
applies oh that thing applies so we get
we get the right thing and I think I
theorem just says that so it says if P
is a mixture esthetical gaussian then
the best state k dimensional surface
contains the centers now this is proved
for the hole density we'll come back to
that in particular if the means of the
gaussians are linearly independent the
space is unique they may depend linearly
they may be dependent then it's not
unique but it still contains all the
center's ok I'm sorry I do have to prove
that so so far
excuse me so far in the last slide we
dealt with a single Gaussian I'm now
just putting it together and saying it's
true for the mixture so and that's
because it's true for each individual
one ok that's what that's next to do so
the expected value of X according to P P
is a mixture is WI this should be P I
excuse me that should be P I so that
should be P I that but if we contains
the Centers of all that then all the
things
in each term here is individually
maximized so the entire sum is contained
there are most K centers you're a
k-dimensional space maybe there are you
need less dimensions because they're
dependent but with K you can put all the
centers and then you are the best
now of course we don't have the whole
density we have finite number samples
there are errors but this is just a
small well not small it requires some
calculation to make sure that it's
correct but believe me it's correct
right the sample lighter the sampling
error can be managed okay so the
algorithm again projecting cluster right
you just project to there sweetie
substation cluster by the way there are
if you've done came in so many
heuristics there is k-means plus plus
all kinds of heuristics like that
nothing guarantees for instance okay so
maybe that's what saying nothing
guarantees what's guaranteed here which
is that you find the correct calcium's
in fact so here is the problem so if you
have two gaussians again same picture
separated by C times Sigma and each of
these have standard deviation Sigma so
they are a distance root P Sigma they
take one of these points with the second
Gaussian it's distance the wrong center
is this squared plus this grade so this
is that distance of said to a right
wrong center squared that's Pythagoras
is this sorry this correct distance
squared which is about D well it's
really root D plus or minus order one
squared plus C squared Sigma square
sorry there's a Sigma squared here too
so that's roughly this quantity is D
times Sigma squared where C squared and
T is going to infinity C is constant so
this is much much smaller than this okay
and this is maybe I should have written
this there for clustering which is which
is error which is relative error okay
means clustering which is relative
errors epsilon can miss cluster every
point right so suppose I only tell you
that I'll give you an algorithm in fact
that's the best you can prove for most
algorithms the exact problems NPR
I'll give you an algorithm that gives
you only relative epsilon in the k-means
objective function but that epsilon can
mean that everybody is wrong in fact you
can put all of these within this cluster
all of these in this cluster there it
would be only epsilon can't miss cluster
every point
so this is the only SVD is only
algorithm I know where you project to
there sweetie saw space in cluster which
can get means separated by two standard
deviations Gaussian correct that SVD
okay dimension algorithm with proof was
not known it's possibly folkloric people
knew that SVD substrates would do the
job right I imagine that's possible but
yeah you you had a good analysis of it
and although there are some extensions
non-spherical gaussians I mean that so
it's I think it's not impossible that
people use this SVD projector and
cluster it's not the most popular method
people usually tried it Lester in the
big space in the space in which data is
given there are some people some
algorithm some papers will do this what
is true for any oh that the mean is the
best thing yes that is true for any
random variable but now but now we have
this mixture right so there are K
different means that's the rub because
you know how do you know which are the
which other which is the partition
that's yeah for one yes okay that's all
I'm going to say about Gaussian mixtures
we are now going to application to which
is maximum cut in a graph this I'm going
to show you because this is unusual is
the discrete problem we'll see how a 3d
can be used to solve I mean you can't
solve the whole problem it's np-hard but
a sweetie can be used to solve some
interesting special cases so we want to
partition the nodes into two there's a
probably just a restatement problem into
two subsets s and we call it s bar
what's rest to maximize the number of
edges from s to s bar right you want to
cut so that the maximum if a is the
adjacency matrix that means one if there
is an edge zero if there's no edge
I can write the problem this way right
because the reason is that oh this is
yeah each X I X I values 0 of I belong
stress it's 1 if I belongs to s power
that's the interpretation so we want to
take all edges a IJ for which they
belong to different sides and that's the
same as saying X I times 1 minus XJ
right if both are 1 or both are 0 this
is 0 the 1 is 1 1 is 0 then it's then
it's 1 so and that you just it's just a
quadratic form over the matrix a so that
looks more like at any algebra thing
it's just X transpose a 1 minus X you
can verify that these two are the same 1
minus X 1 is the vector of all ones so
we want to maximize that it's np-hard
will see that for dense graphs now dense
graphs is the one class I'm going to
show you using a sweetie there are the
classes but this is what I'm going to
show you dense good then this graph
means it has a constant fraction of all
possible edges we can use SVD to find a
near optimal solution in polynomial time
near optimal means relative Epsilon so
for every dense graph you can do this
there are other ways of doing it for
dense graphs alone but a sweetie is the
only way of doing it for some other so
for a more general class of graphs I
won't show you that so what we will show
here's a summary of what we'll show and
then we have to go into the details so
remember this quantity that I I did
there sweetie
and then I truncate it after the K term
so you I and VI or the singular vectors
left and right and this is a sweetie but
I finished I chopped it off at K and
will maximize X transpose a K 1 minus X
naught a is for the day right subject to
the same condition will show two things
for any 0 1 vector X these two are close
a k and a or close this is easy part
right so what I'm saying is if I did the
optimization with a K I shouldn't suffer
too much error because they're close
I can choose k k is my choice I can
choose it high so that I make a small
error as K grows right as K grows I'm
solving more and more complicated
problems I should gain some and that's
what I'm gaining the error is going down
to 0 as K goes to infinity and the
harder part is that you can in fact find
solve ik ake a problem in polynomial
time if K is fixed by exploiting the low
rank of a so later I'll put up a model
so if problems in K dimension can be
solved in general in time exponential
only in K so if you have a
two-dimensional problem you can always
solve it in polynomial time right let's
say that's the moral of this story bill
will explain that so again all I'm doing
is just write it as a quadratic form
approximated by a sweetie and solve and
we'll see that that's a good solution
sorry K cannot be more than n if at K we
would like it to be constant the error
oh error goes to 0 as K okay
so as I should say the following in a
dense Kraft there's always a max cut of
there's a cut of size at least half M
Squared okay is what saying that you
know so yeah exactly
random yeah max cut is greater than or
equal to half inch square in size
because for a random subset s the cut
the expectation of the cut is half m
square half half the number of edges
excuse me this is north half and squid
this is half the number of edges but
they assume this is all the N squared
right so there's only the expectation
but you can argue that there's always a
cut with high probability so if I just
randomly put each vertex in their sport
rest bar part I take an individual edge
it has half probability of being in the
cut right and it's just its expectation
so I can add up over all edges each edge
is 1/2 probability of contributing to
the cut so the total is at least as much
therefore this error is not so bad if I
make K a million or something this will
be thousand so I make only one
thousandth of the end ok so first I want
to prove a somewhat easier part that egg
approximation is not bad so X and 1
minus 1 so 0 1 vector so the length is
that most root n for each of them and so
we can write the difference between
these two real numbers is that quantity
right I mean so here all I've done is
there's a spectral long times 1 minus X
oh I should have said 1 minus X excuse
me here I should have said 1 minus X and
so this touch is speckle long times that
and that's cauchy-schwarz now do that
and so that's at most n times the
spectral norm so why is this small why
is the spectral norm of a minus akk
small we proved that SVD was the best
ranked approximation inspector law
therefore the error is that most there
is exactly Sigma K plus 1 of a and now
why is that small well we see that
here's a little inequality I take K plus
1 times this since the Sigma's are in
decreasing order that's less than or
equal to that but that's the sum of some
singular values sum of all the single
value squared is this so it's less than
that now this is just a IJ squared
zero-one so that's at most n squared and
therefore you get n here and you get
this is N squared over K plus 1 and that
all works out right so you get that and
you get another n out of that ok so the
approximation is correct now I want to
exploit the low rank of a to solve the
problem quickly and again the moral of
the story is any problem in K dimensions
can be solved in time roughly
exponential in K you have to do some
work to get it in different context but
we'll get it in this context but it's
true for in general thing sort of okay
so we'll see how to do this so this this
requires a little bit of grunge
technical stuff unfortunately we have to
do that first look at the case first I
want to point out that it's not
completely trivial look at the case when
K equals 1 and even the special case
when u equals V and that's already
np-hard so you can't just do even the K
equals 1 case exactly I want to do the
following now I want to maximize X
transpose a K and now I'm assuming a K
equals Sigma 1 you want and the same u 1
transpose you're assuming that and I
want to maximize X transpose 1 minus X X
is 0 1 in s or not in s so that's just
equal to Sigma 1 and just a dot product
of these two dot product of these two
but this is 0 1 vector so that's the sum
of a subset of coordinates right so let
me just call it u 1 u so that's the sum
of I belonging to s UI and this is the
sum of I not belonging to s that's 1
minus X UI
okay sorry here's a partition exactly
right yeah so okay sorry so I didn't say
yeah it's a partition problem so this is
just maximizing this I give you a vector
I want to split it into two so that the
product is maximized maximized name and
that's the same as saying the best
possibility best if small I belonging to
ask you I equals into the you sum of all
the US is fixed so the best you can do
is it partition equally and the question
of can i partition it equally is np-hard
I'll give you a bunch of real numbers
and I want to know if I can partition to
two parts of the sums are equal that's
np-hard
so the exact problem is pretty hard even
for K equals 1 but but there's a simple
dynamic programming algorithm which
finds a near optimal solution for 1 for
1 vector if you will but we will use
that for K vectors we write U is as a
sum of U IJ j belonging to s similarly
for y here we want to find the s that
maximizes this now there are K things
not one thing using dynamic programming
so what is that it's just a recap of
dynamic programming as I said this will
be a little technical but let's go with
that so what I need what I'm going to
find let's say for now for every
subsidise I'm going to find u 1 of s so
that's just that some we wanted s bar
and all of these things I'm going to
find for every s if you had a list of
all of them once I tell you what these
are I can find this right I can find
this and take the maximum so we can find
that quantity for each s and then take
the maximum but there are 2 to the N
subsets right that's not good and you
can ask whether there are ties they need
not be ties because these are badly
these could be real numbers these
components of singular vectors they're
singular vectors of a a was a nice
matrix 0 1 but the components of
singular vectors could be arbitrary real
numbers and so there may not be any ties
what we do tell why that is round the
coordinate so that they become not real
numbers but multiples of 1 over integer
so you want to make them all in integer
multiples of 1 over N K squared call the
rounded vectors that and then we take
the rounded this and now we'll prove
that there are not too many such so lot
for a lot of s as these vectors will be
tight because we've rounded basically
right there are very few values there so
for a lot of SS this will be tied the
number of distinct
possibilities for those vectors north is
not very big and we'll just go over all
of them and construct by dynamic
programming list of all possible values
of w prime s it turns out there'll be
only this many values of this you have
to do a little calculation I won't do
that which will imply this many values
so basically there are only this many
distinct sets s which lead to distinct
vectors so the number of SS is very
small is the exponent is only kick right
the exponent doesn't involve and it
involves only K that's the point now you
have to show that the error is not too
much and again perhaps you don't follow
all the details because it may be grungy
but let me just quickly run over that so
these are length 1 vectors and the sum
over a subset is at most root n you take
a length on vector sum its components it
should be at most root n and so the
difference is at most K squared and same
for VI this is a bit of a calculation
it's a it's a it's a quadratic term this
is just saying well this is just saying
don't worry about this this is just
saying a and B a two real numbers I'm
estimating a by a prime B by B Prime and
this is saying I'm doing a good estimate
of the product yeah I mean that's
believable right it just says to pin it
down that's all so here we're doing that
right wait the product of two numbers
they're estimating this well this well
therefore the product well that's that
calculation and the theorem is given a
directed graph a cut of size at least
the maximum cut - this much can be
computed in time polynomial in N and for
fixed K that's what comes out of this
again
bear with me or with all the
calculations the idea was simple right
the idea was I approximated a by a rank
K matrix right and enough to solve that
problem Brian came in K dimensions I
could enumerate in salt so one other way
to think about the enumeration is
instead of
algebraically I'm sitting in k-space I
just put down a grid I want to find the
best solution in k-space
I just put down a grid find enough grid
so if this distance is Delta the number
of grid points it's less than or equal
to 1 over Delta to the K well the
diameter to the king but the exponent is
only K that's all I'm using now what I
don't have time to present is one line I
want to state in fact it turns out this
kind of method take a matrix
approximated by a low rank matrix and
solve the optimization problem on low
rank is useful for a quite a class of
discrete optimization problems see I
won't define this max CSP includes the
following kind of problem for instance
you might have a boolean expression
3-cnf three literals per clause and I
want to know the maximum number of
clauses that I can satisfy
so I want to maximum number of closes I
can satisfy that can be solved by these
kinds of method but if you had three
liters per plots you have to approximate
it three times if you had L literals for
Clause you have to approximate in L
tensor but the game plan would be the
same again I won't go through this the
game plan will be the same is the same
you take the tensor which defines this
problem I haven't told you how but it
defines this problem and then you
approximate the tensor by a low rank
tensor and then solve the problem show
that this same approximation method
works so it turns out it can do that one
other thing that's worth noting that can
be done
is if you have any matrix a non-negative
entries satisfying triangle inequality
triangle inequality means a IJ that
implies a has a good-enough low-rank
approximation and you can do the problem
on that
so for instance if you had if your
maxcut problem to solve on such a matrix
you can do it relative to relative
Epsilon
like for dance and the event that is the
same except you have to scale the rows
of a matrix a and then there's a good
lowering so I think that's all I have to
say elaborate on any of these that's the
end of the well that may be discussion
but otherwise this was directed but you
can do undirected also yeah same same
thing right so this does not give you
multiplicative guarantees it only gives
you multiple you drink guarantees for
max cut pro but if triangle inequalities
or something is true right but it our
for dense graphs what there's a general
class in putting those but it doesn't in
general give you multiplicative
guarantees like the STP things too but
it's faster if yeah it's much faster you
just sample these things and solve so if
epsilon K has to be at least one over
epsilon squared yeah I mean for the
theoretical result right if you want
epsilon squared error yeah so that may
be you know that will be high I mean in
the tail for the theorem in practice
maybe you know it can work right it's
yeah it should be if they think that is
declined faster then you should be able
to do better right this is saying the
top k plus 1 are all equal in fact so so
this is the worst case that true for
every matrix but it should be better for
power law matrices or good spectrum
I guess for a random matrix it won't be
better than this but so so if it's not
dense if it's sparse
then finding the exact thing is hard so
even if it's slightly spicy it so I
think the improvement beyond one over
epsilon square is not possible that is
known by this method and all the exact
problems are so I mean in theory there
are many papers proving the e/m
algorithm does not work right in fact it
is yeah
any pathological don't have that
something Oh
whether it was for dense things for
instance I doubt actually that it works
so easily for any of these things so so
actually here's the thing suppose you
have a mixture of k calcium's
no algorithm I know except SVD ever
finds anybody any points within a few
standard deviations of the center so I
want an initial start right k-means
completely fails as the start is bad so
if the start has a property that my
starting centers are within a few stand
constant number of standard deviations
of the real center then you're in luck
right but no other algorithm insures
that except this VD so k-means
clustering or ensure that because pics
data points data points are very far
from the center so there is a proof
there are some papers that say m does
not work for so I have to quantify I
mean qualify that same writing if you
had a bad start
so yeah to say yeah I think if you have
to circle gaussians and you start with
two centers which are both from one
Gaussian then you're sunk I think that's
true for a year more k-means or any of
these
because they can't escape you can't
escape from the local and I think that's
all these proofs say in fact probably it
is true that if I start from centers one
for each Gaussian which is within a few
standard deviations of the real center
probably convergence holes for many
algorithms
I would guess but but I don't maybe I
haven't seen the reader choice
I shouldn't venture but yeah so it does
do something for a non circle Gaussian
so it's been worked out what it gives it
does give something in general if you
have non spherical gaussians the
center's are separated by a constant
number of the maximum possible standard
deviation of any of the Gaussian in any
direction then this whole thing works
you can have two very big gaussians
separated by a few standing this sort of
thing then then we don't have a proof
thank you yeah no we have to assume the
number of samples of each Gaussian is at
least one over the weight right
otherwise you can't detect it but I
escaped all that by going to infinite
number of samples I looked at the whole
density but it's true finite sample
error things you have to worry about how
many samples came from each cousin so I
think that actually people worry about
so I think it is not known how of course
it's not known how to it cannot beat one
over the weight but I think you can't
even beat one of the weight squared and
I'll go them so far okay thanks